herzlich willkommen zum Q&A von unserer
Reportage mystische Gänge was ist ihr
Geheimnis als allererst mal es mega
großes merci für die zahlreiche
Kommentar weil ich heuer als Rätsel
nicht wirklich Analyse aber ihre dafür
umso mehr der Kommentar Theorie
diskutiert und besprochen als allererst
wird dich darum gerade auch ein Wort für
die meisten Theorie am Lukas Studer
danke vielmals ganze 4 Kommentar bzw
Theorie geschrieben das ist Aufbewahrung
zu Aufenthaltsraum
Vergangenheit in der Hoffnung auf
Edelmetall stoße bezüglich der
edelmetalköniginal kommentarische
Bewohner wie zum Beispiel davon
ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass die
Gänge gegraben wurden und Metalle wie
zum Beispiel Eisen zu finden die Theorie
bzw
gleitet er schaffe dir bitte Kantons
Archäologie in Bayern er sei zu der
Theorie folgendes die Stollen die ich
kenn liegen alle im Sandsteinfels
Molasse dort kann es aus geologischen
Gründen kein Gold und Silber und auch
keine weiteren Metalle in abbaubaren
Mengen geben und ich gehe davon aus dass
das die damaligen Menschen wussten die
gleichtheorie kann
sie führt das ganze noch bis los sie
seid es sind Ablagerungen von Flüssen
welche aus den entstehenden Alpen ins
Unterland Flossen und ihm damaligen
Molasse mehr oder auf dem Festland den
Schutt fein verteilten darum kann man
dir Theorie vermutlich Ausschlüsse
andere Kommentare zum Beispiel gibt's
weniger mystisch vielleicht auch einfach
nur als Depot für Nahrungsmittel
verwendet wurden die kühlschranktheorie
das ist schon andere Theorie wo auf
kommentiert wurden
das das ist grundsätzlich nicht
auszuschließen wenn ich aber einen
Kühlraum in Sandstein Untergrund
schaffen wollte würde ich den Gang nur
wenige Meter schmal anlegen und ihn dann
zu einer Kamera erweitern in der Platz
ist um ein Gestell oder ähnliches
aufzustellen 20 oder 30 Meter lange und
schmale Gänge machen da keinen Sinn
außerdem würde man Aufhängevorrichtungen
oder Haken an der Decke erwarten um
etwas Schinken oder ähnliches aufhängen
zu können
und Frau wiederseits du hast einige
Gänge selber gesehen würdest du sie als
Kühlschrank verwenden da wäre doch ein
Keller unter oder neben einem Haus
besser da ist der Inhalt auch vor dem
geschützt und die Raumgröße entspricht
dem Bedürfnissen also ich fand das
selber auch relativ komisch sondern 30
Meter langer Stöcke gerade Gang als
Kühlschrank zu Buche was aber falls ich
glaube die Theorie spricht ist dass man
nun hier organische Materialien in einer
Gang gefunden
gar nicht also darum für mich jetzt auch
eher unwahrscheinlich Theorie war für
mich aber mega plausibel und die andere
über Instagram geschickt er kann ihn
nämlich so stelle
ich vor der Stadtbahn im Umkreis noch
geeignetem sandsteingraben worden ist
man hätte im Bantiger das ist ein
Bergbahn das
sandsteiner Altstadt der Theorie bin ich
ist aber nur nie wieder machen weil sie
erst gerade vorher ganz frisch und dem
eigentlich Korrektur es ist wo bei der
ganzen Archäologie thematikli unter der
tischkate ist und der herbariswil hat
mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht weil ich
kann im Film gesagt das eine von der
Hauptgrund wieso sich Archäologie
aber falsch weil der Hauptgrund ist dass
die Stelle nicht unmittelbar vor der
Zerstörung bedroht sind denn
Hauptaufgabe von der Archäologie ist es
in erster Linie Fundstelle
wissenschaftlich bearbeiten wo war der
Baumaßnahme zerstört werden also so viel
nur zudem denn der Bastler fragt nur ob
man etwas
so zwei Meter aber gar nicht
ähm ich sagen dass Jungs vorhanden war
18b nachdem ich dick Sie wie sich nur
Akzente aber gegangen sind aber sicher
nicht spezielle gefunden und apropos
haben wir schwarzer B zu Ina hat ich so
zwei drei kritische Kommentare erhalten
wo alle richtig gleich richtig gönnt und
fragen wieso ich denn überhaupt der
Plattform gehabt wie zum Beispiel da
Kommentar da Robin macht bei fardy
absurdesten und stupidesten Reportagen
bei SRF kein Wunder dass sogar die
Verschwörung wurde von Hangar 18 BS
sehen und für großartige empfinden
lieber Robin solchen Leuten bietet man
keine Plattform danke für die in meine
glückset werde ich das 1984 dass ich mit
meiner Reportage nicht der Geschmack vor
jeder und jedem trifft dass ich mir
selber mega klar
mini-reportage aber das bezeichnet nur
weil ich quasi lügt oder deren Meiningen
das finde ich nicht schade weil dazu
muss man folgendes verstauen wenn man zu
Arztstelle oder deine mystische Gang
oder recherchieren
Videos kommen nicht verbiegt das heißt
sie haben mir durch das auch Zugang zu
deiner Stelle verschafft also ich kann
mit ihnen Diskussion können sie haben
Zugang verschafft sie haben nämlich auch
genau gewusst wo die Ersteller sind und
so habe ich mir selber weil das Bild
machen weil vor der Archäologe und
Archäologinnen hat mich niemandem
klar ich gebe ihnen Plattform aber ich
ordne mega stark dass dir absurde
Theorie für die sie auch offen sind vor
einer einzige Person bzw
ein Scharlatan fast hätte ich seine
Bücher gekauft aber glücklicherweise
habe ich mich vorher über den Schlag
gemacht andere wiederum sage zum
Beispiel da wieder außer dem Goku wenn
ihr mehr wissen wollte über diese Gänge
solltet ihr Heinrich Kusch eingeben ja
der Heinrich Kusch er ist
ganze alien-theorie und Beamer und
Versicherungs
sehr intensiv mit seiner Theorie und
auch Rezensionen
kritisiert wurde sind und auch auf mich
keine wirklich seriöse Eindruck gemacht
denn nachdem ich mich wirklich intensiv
mit einer Theorie angesetzt da das ist
ja der Grund wieso der Reportage nicht
wieder drauf gegangen bin und das ist ja
der Grund dass sich in der Forschung
praktisch niemand mit seiner Theorie
auseinandersetzt weil einfach so viel
wissenschaftliche Faller bin da Tiere
und bequem und so gemacht wurde sind vor
dass da alle ich schlafe dann in der
Theorie Lektion bitte
ganz interessante Theorie behandelt
.g.2 LB schreibt
vielleicht muss man gar nicht so weit
suchen und es war lediglich der Spaß am
Graben Stichwort Minecraft
vielleicht
weiß es nicht danke fürs zuschauen